um okay we are taking calls through
Discord remember if you want even a
chance of getting on your nickname has
to have your name and where you're
calling in from so I see folks with
nicknames or no location or or you know
inside jokes or whatever you won't get
called on unless you have the proper
delineation like for example Jess from
Oregon Jess from Oregon you were able to
figure out how to correctly set up your
nickname and now you're on the show
oh wonderful
um I uh wanted to ask you about the uh
have you seen uh these environmental
protests like environmentalist
protesters who have been throwing food
on uh paintings and then gluing their
hand to the wall yes I have
okay my question for you is uh as a you
know we're we're both pretty young
people who care about the Earth does
this do anything is this giving
um attention to is this like
calling attention to the right people is
this I don't think Jess I think that
this is a terribly misguided form of
protest now one of the arguments that's
made is but listen David now you and
Jess are talking about it yes we're
talking about it but the context isn't
that the attempted destruction of a van
Gogh painting has now made Jess and I
start donating to end world hunger right
we're talking about it as wow this is
really misguided now I am sympathetic to
the view that if you only do protests in
the ways that everybody agrees you
should do them you will achieve nothing
in many cases it's it's understood that
sometimes you've got to make people a
little uncomfortable or you've gotta
kind of insert yourself into a situation
but destroying artwork Priceless artwork
historically significant artwork to make
the case that we should be focused on
the climate or on hunger or whatever
I don't think is actually achieving that
and if you look at the conversations
about these attempts to to you know
throw the paint and all this other stuff
it's mentioned that oh and it was
because of hunger but nobody goes wow
that's really what our focus should be
let's go donate to end Hunger people go
this is the wrong way to go about it the
the motivation becomes not even
secondary it becomes almost irrelevant
and there I don't believe they're
achieving anything at all yeah I think
it's um it's it's uh I'm sorry it is
creating a spectacle instead of creating
something thought-provoking right right
all right well thank you very much for
your input thank you Jess everything
good in Oregon there
no it's I mean it's Smoky but
all right well appreciate hearing from
you thanks so much all right there goes
Jess from Oregon bringing up a very
important issue the chances that your
login credentials have been leaked in a
data breach are higher than you might
think but you can actually check if you
go to aura.com Pacman you can try Aura
for free our sponsor Aura scans the dark
web for your personal information login
credentials social security number and
sends you alerts sign up and you could
be shocked to see how many alerts you
get on Aura one of our team members
found his login credentials in three
different data breaches now of course he
changed his passwords right away I've
told you before about one of my accounts
getting hacked scary feeling but Aura
also does so much more by automatically
requesting the removal of information
from data search engines giving you fast
alerts on suspicious credit inquiries or
it has password management malware
protection for all of your devices and
Aura also helps you manage what your
kids can do on their devices by
restricting certain apps it's really
like a Swiss army knife of online
security and you can try Aura for free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman the
link is down below